you talked about how you kind of weight
around it oh you've emailed 10 people
today and I how I got back to you what
I've noticed just from my short time
doing this is that the people that are
really successful they're great at
following up on email yeah no I think
that's true I think that's absolutely
true and you you know I try I try to be
that because it drives me nuts you know
when we try to remember the golden rule
as much as I can in his business like
you know how would I respond if I was
that guy um because all I'm trying to do
is get this thing from A to B that's all
I want and I feel like if people would
get out of the way it would work a lot
easier but sometimes you know you gotta
do this back and forth these email
chains it takes nine emails to get one
thing done and that like that is so true
hey yeah it's frustrating but and it
drives me crazy and the people in my
office get really tired of hearing me
about it but it's probably the
thing that drives me the most crazy is
just the menial mess of just trying to
get something done but there's no reason
it shouldn't be easy you know I'm not
really asking for anything special just
do that you know I don't know every
situation is different but man I hate
those emails
you